so then when a person's sitting in a
meditation and they're doing absolutely
nothing and it's eight o'clock in the
morning and their body for the last 10
years has been going in traffic and
getting angry and frustrated in traffic
and now they're sitting in a meditation
at eight o'clock in the morning the
body's gonna say hey you're off schedule
so the body's gonna start looking for
that emotion and it's going to start
influencing the mind and you're going to
start getting images and memories just
so you can feel that emotion like now
the person's back in the past but if
they become aware that they're siphoning
energy out of the present moment into
the past and they settle the body back
down into the present moment that's a
victory and those victories add up and
you're telling the body in that moment
that it's no longer the mind that you're
the mind and that's a victory and then
people get frustrated and they say I
can't meditate oh really well actually
you're doing it right that's actually
what meta test you're doing exactly what
you're supposed to be doing and all of a
sudden the body says well it's 8 15 now
this is when you normally you know go
get something to eat and you have your
coffee and your body's starting to want
to get up and do something become aware
that your body wants to get up and move
and you're in the meditation and you
tell your body uh-uh you bring it back
the present moment you settle it back
down you are training the animal that's
a victory now you're executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
program now you're telling the body I'll
tell you when we get up not when you
want to get up you're not the mind I'm
the mind and that's a victory hey seven
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggle
to stay afloat I quit I'm a business
partner and the thing that kept me
motivated kept me going was studying the
stories of famous successful
entrepreneurs and in their stories it
gave me the hope the drive the ambition
the thinking that maybe I can do it too
that exhibited belief and I still need
their stories today and I'm honored to
share them with you here as well so
today let's learn how to meditate enjoy
we've done the research on this
if you keep doing this and you stay with
it sooner or later the body is going to
surrender to a new mind and when that
happens Sean
there's a liberation of energy the body
is freed from those habituations and
those emotions the bodies going from
particle to wave from matter to energy
and all of a sudden you're dialing down
the anger you're dialing down the
vigilance and the body now is being
conditioned to a new mind that is the
present moment and when you're in that
present moment something really amazing
happens you forget about you
all of a sudden you're not your face
you're not your culture you're not your
your marital status you're not your diet
you're not your your past you're
basically just an awareness you're in
the unknown and that is the perfect
place to create from so it turns out
that when people do this properly they
heal themselves of anxiety why because
they're no longer obsessing about some
future
when they find the present moment they
heal their from their depression because
they're not a bit hopeless and Powerless
in their past the body's conditioned now
and so then
when they overcome themselves in their
meditation
and they step out into their life they
are more present they can connect they
are more patient they are more loving
because they overcome the animal part of
themselves and the beauty behind that is
is that all of a sudden you're not
predictable all of a sudden something's
different about Sean he's he's not I'm
noticing he's not behaving the same way
you're out of the known right you're in
the unknown and all of a sudden people
is no longer what you're saying to them
is who you are they're just kind of
scratching their head going hey he looks
like he's really happy I want some of
that and now we're out of the
philosophical theoretical realm we're in
the practicum which is where really the
magic happens so the Eternal Present
Moment The Sweet Spot of the generous
present moment is the place we create
from and when we are when we're there we
disconnect from our bodies we become
nobody
we disconnect from people in our lives
we're not thinking about our ex or our
boss we are no one we're not thinking
about our cell phone our computer we are
no thing we are not thinking about where
we live where we work where we sleep we
are nowhere and we're not thinking about
the predictable future and the familiar
past we're in no time and when you're
disconnecting or dissociating from
everything known you're in the unknown
and that's where the magic happens I
have found in the absolute worst times
of my life
meditation can get me back to zero every
single time meaning I have absolutely no
physiological remnants of stress or
anxiety it is so amazing and so powerful
that I only wish that I'd started doing
it years earlier and it was Mark Devine
the Navy SEAL that I was talking about
before that helped me realize because I
thought of it as very
um weak and effeminate which growing up
feeling like a weak effeminate kid
getting tough and getting stronger has
been a huge part of my journey so I
didn't want to do anything that I felt
was moving me backwards now he was the
one that slapped me around and was like
look
it just makes sense it's getting you out
of that sympathetic and into the
parasympathetic and so I thought well if
it's good enough for a Navy SEAL then
it's good enough for me I tried it and
it was life changing and there have been
times in my life since I started
meditating I honestly don't know how I
would have made it through
um if I didn't have meditation because
that ability to get back to equilibrium
to zero with what I call no background
radiation
um it's so powerful so meditation has
become a huge way for me to to manage
anxiety which is really really powerful
so there it is and I will do one quick
cycle so you can see how deadly simple
it is I normally sit cross-legged so
take that for what it's worth but I'll
do it just normally seated now
I do it with my eyes closed and I
breathe in through my nose out through
my mouth and it looks like this
hey hey there it is all right nice and
easy um I did the second part of the
cycle so you can see how long that I
usually end up holding that exhale hold
again I just do it until it's not
pleasurable anymore I don't feel like
I'm holding my breath it literally just
feels like an exhale and it's so weird
even in that short cycle I almost forgot
I was doing an AMA uh that's how
powerful meditation has become for me I
I get lost so rapidly if I'd had this is
the last thing I do when I meditate I
put headphones on over the ear
headphones and I listen to The Calm app
I do not do guided meditation some
people love it I absolutely hate it and
I listen to the sounds of nature and I
find that insanely powerful and if I had
had my headphones on I do fear that I
actually would have forgotten I was
doing this but that's how quickly you
can with practice and I've been doing it
now for about three years
um with practice you can get into a
super chill State meditation is very
very simple in the simplest sense
the simplest meditation nowadays that's
taught is 15 minutes in the morning 15
at night sit down and watch your breath
go in and out well what's so Holy by
watching your breath go in and out if
you are watching your breath go in and
out you are not watching your mind
complain about what's going on
you're not letting your mind you're not
watching the mind that is participating
in the game of what I want what do I not
want and how do I make it happen you are
instead focusing your awareness on the
breath going in and out believe it or
not that will completely change your
life why
for the very reason that you're not
participating in the Disturbed mind the
mind will always be disturbed if the
foundation of the mind is what do I want
what do I not want and how do I make it
happen
that is very disturbing because you have
pitted yourself against the unfolding of
reality in front of you if you watch
your breath go in and out or any other
technique of meditation you use whatever
is comfortable to you works for you if
you're watching your breath go in and
out you're not watching your mind live
your life decide what should be
happening and getting upset or excited
about it that very Act of not watching
the Disturbed mind permits you you in
there the one that I said are you in
there hi
you're in there but you're watching your
mind all the time and participating in
the mind's attempt to make things be the
way it wants also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
there's a new kind of meditation that
I'm encouraging you to try and it's
based on the Neuroscience that we know
it goes something like this it has to do
with the fact that our goal is to get
present right you breathe you get
present you become less reactive it's
very important only in your daily life
you want to be present but you also want
to dream big and go for things and
access your creativity which is about
being not present it's about not right
now not being limited by right here
right now but then you have to turn
around that great idea and turn into
something up to implement so how do you
bridge those things one of the things
that makes us remarkable is our ability
to bridge time as a species again my dog
Costello doesn't wake up on New Year's
Day 2016 and say 50 rabbits this year
you know that's what makes dogs so
present and that's what makes us so
neurotic is that we leave this space we
go elsewhere but leaving is good too
because leaving is the reason that Steve
Jobs is able to create objects that
didn't exist before like the iPhone that
we're all such a slave to now right so
how do you do this so there's three
kinds of General themes of meditation
I'm not an expert in meditation and then
I promise I'll wrap up which is the
first thing you want to what I recommend
just trying try it and let me know send
me an email let me know how it goes is
one meditation very short five minutes
where for one breath one breath you
close your eyes and go internal and you
get behind and some people call it the
third eye right I'm gonna get the the
language wrong but we all know what
we're talking about you get inside your
breath and then the second thing you do
is you focus on something at a short
distance there's a powerful system in
your brain when you focus both eyes on a
single point like a watchmaker making a
watch or you're reading that state is
accessing very specific channels in your
brain that are very different from the
one that when you close your eyes okay
and it's called a virgin's eye movement
when you put both your eyes on the same
thing and then the last one is the one
that we get a lot of here that feeling
awesome feeling when you go out to the
beach or you're on the top of a mountain
or you look at the horizon or you arrive
in New York City if you're me and you
just go oh my God and you're defocused
and that's when you're these ideas the
creativity kind of spontaneously geysers
Up From Below but then you have to get
back and you need to get to work on
something and so the what's been very
powerful and we're going to put we're
putting patients through this or
subjects in brain Imaging is this way of
accessing all these different brain
States is really about accessing
different Notions of space and time
trying to get access to your whole brain
and it's a short meditation I recommend
just one breath at each of these kind of
stations in your mind up close and
focusing on your hand and out and I'll
repeat that a few times during my
morning or maybe once or twice during
the day it's quick and we're getting
remarkable feedback
from the people who are doing this about
the kind of state that it puts them in
both engaged and present with the bigger
picture and in the end it's all about
the bigger picture right because it's
about not just what you do with your
life but how you're going to create good
in the world how would you define
meditation
well there's different there are
different types of meditation usually
either way we I would say there's no
form of meditation where we're focused
on our brain okay good I'm glad we
disagree yeah um no I would say here are
the things that happen we either are
engaging in a mantra which would be a
version of a
almost like a creating a trance for
ourselves
not unlike listening something when we
go to sleep that would distract our
conscious mind from
participating we would be overriding our
uh the talking mind with just a sound
that we're generating or a word or a
phrase series of phrases
meta meditation is
um a loving kindness meditation with
phrases could be that or it could be
focused on the breath but the purpose of
being focused on the breath is to not
hear the self-talk that we normally have
it's a it's a single pointed Focus
exercise in those that I described the
other version is an awareness meditation
where you're closing your eyes and
you're being with whatever is
and noticing
so if we were to do it now and you could
do an eyes opener eyes closed with an
awareness practice
but the first thing that I would do is I
would feel um
I feel a little ringing in my ears might
be from the electronic equipment around
us that I don't mean that I hear the
sound it's like a vibration I hear cars
passing in the distance
what else comes up
I can feel uh feeling
in my chest
I can feel
um
this part of my face
sure why
it feels like it's related to my jaw
more car sounds
I'm aware of a little feeling of warmth
so now I would say the room the room it
feels a bit warm I wasn't aware of that
before when I wasn't
just being with what's happening
I feel a little itch on my left shoulder
so you know that that would be an
awareness practice which is another kind
of meditation where you just paying
attention what's going on there's no
story there's no this means this none of
those things just
like an inventory almost of everything
that comes up when it comes up and you
do that for a period of time if you
struggle like me to sit down every
morning close your eyes and meditate
I've got some great news for you that's
not the only form of meditation the
traditional form of meditation
crisscross applesauce
um it's not the only way to practice
mindfulness there are three things you
can do to find moments of meditation
throughout your day and if you do them
consistently it's gonna have really
similar benefits number one hobbies that
you enjoy can be a moment of meditation
if they're active Hobbies where you're
strictly focused on the task at hand
while you're doing something like adult
coloring books cooking knitting going
for a run walking in the woods without
listening to anything
Believe It or Not research even shows
that Tetris is a powerful form of
meditation what doesn't count is sitting
passively watching TV but hobbies that
Focus your mind on a task creates
moments of meditation now a second form
of practicing a moment of meditation is
to Simply laser focus in on some detail
in the present moment for example pull
your attention to the present moment and
focus on something around you like
holding a cup of coffee and noticing how
warm it is in your hands or I do this
all the time I stand in line at a
grocery store
and I pay attention to my breathing and
I clench my stomach or you could eat a
handful of almonds one by one and notice
how each singular almond tastes
different from the others taking a
moment of meditation through the day is
a simple way to train your mind to come
back to the present moment and here's a
third way that you can practice being
mindful without meditating
create a positive trigger that brings
your attention to the present moment
it could be every time I walk through a
doorway I'm going to take a deep breath
you might want to set an alarm on your
phone that goes off and says
stay in the moment you want to know my
trigger whenever I catch myself
slouching I realize I'm slouching and I
take a minute and I ah pull my shoulders
back and I roll my neck and I
take a deep belly breath
and I'm right back in the moment so stop
beating yourself up for not being a monk
or a yoga instructor or a meditation
Guru and give yourself a break just
practice moments of meditation
so I have a slightly different take on
meditation and if you've been struggling
with meditation in your life this might
help I first thought believe in the
power of meditation I believe the
science I believe all the studies and I
used to judge myself and feel really bad
about it because I I felt like I
couldn't meditate I would sit there on
the couch or on the pillow or on the bed
or lie down and I never felt anything
when I was meditated I could sit and I
could be present and I could I could I
could do it and then and I could sit
there for 20 minutes and it felt like 20
minutes
but I never felt any different I think
that was where it started to shift for
me is not that I didn't feel anything in
the moment but never felt any different
coming out and I've meditated with some
of the
the the best meditation teachers
um on the planet and it's never really
led to an impact for me uh in the moment
or afterwards or sustained and I again
would judge myself really harshly like
hey I mean I I want to make this work
how do I make this work I Believe In The
Sciences go and make it work
what I've distilled it down to is into
two parts one is a lot of meditation a
lot of benefits I believe from
meditation are really just about being
present and being Mindful and that is
something that I can do a lot more
naturally than maybe most people and I
don't find a lot of benefit in it
because I'm more there than not so I I'm
85 present 15 future focused and zero
percent pass focus when you are thinking
about the past it's usually really
negative way sometimes we like pass Look
Backwards into the past and it's
gratitude and and remembering great
memories and
um you know looking all the great things
we've done but for the most part when
you look backwards it's negative it's
regrets it's I wish I did this or why
did that person do that to me or I wish
I had said something different we're
we're looking negatively on our past
mostly through the lens of regret and
what you did or what other people did
and when you're looking forward
entrepreneurs love looking forward and
the vision and the building what you can
create and all the amazing things but a
lot of looking forward is also
uncertainty in Stress and Anxiety in
what may happen and what could happen
and what might happen if x happens and
just we're stuck in these negative Loops
a lot of the backwards thinking is
negative through the lens of regret and
a lot of the Forward Thinking is
negative through the lens of anxiety
stress and worry and so that's where hey
if you're present-minded you're going to
be a lot happier you're going to be a
lot more focused right if you're just
thinking about what you should have done
or what might happen to you you're not
actually able to be productive and get
stuff out right now in the present and
so the the job becomes how do I stay
present and I think a lot of that is
accomplished through meditation for most
people if you're if you're in a state of
stress thinking about the regret of the
past or anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focus in on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
that can help calm you down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to
be able to be productive uh solve the
problem be happy because you're being
more present so for me that's actually
quite easy I'm in the present uh a lot
more than anywhere else and I used to
think it as a negative a friend of mine
used to make fun of me for having a bad
memory he's like you're such a bad
memory he's like and I later realized I
I don't have a bad memory I I want to
remember what's important to me but two
I'm not living in the past like I don't
care about what happened I'm looking at
right now today I don't know what day it
is I don't know what day it is I don't
know I I know it's 2022 when recording
this I'd have to think about what month
it is
I don't know what I'm doing after
recording this video I don't know what I
did yesterday I don't know what I'm
doing tomorrow let alone once I press
stop on this video I am here with you
this is this is my entire attention is
making this video right now that's it
this is this is the present moment for
me and what I've discovered is
this is meditation
at least the the portion of it where
you're getting back to present moment if
that's one of the main benefits of
meditation then this is meditation for
me I'm only in the present moment right
now being here talking with you guys and
that's it
and I realized that most of my life is
lived like that yes I love planning for
where I'm gonna go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in in
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend gonna look like
weekend I don't even know what I'm doing
in the next hour let alone what I'm
doing this weekend and when people ask
me on a Monday how was your weekend like
I don't know
that was that was that was yesterday
that was two days ago I'm I got stuff to
do right now I'm working on my life
right now and and not just work even
just enjoying even just life even just
me spending time with with my wife or my
son or on a trip it's like let's enjoy
this moment where we're at right now and
so if that's you I would introduce the
idea of hey that's a different
perspective shift like maybe you are
meditating right now and you might be
over judging yourself because if you're
in the present that's one of the biggest
benefits one of my favorite things to do
every morning is I go on a belief walk
and I found when a lot of people would
say oh I get my best ideas when I'm
meditate it if I get creative
breakthroughs when I'm meditating part
of that that I believe is hey you've
unblocked yourself from the past and the
future the regrets of the past the
stress of the future to get back to
present which then calms you down to
then that should be more creative and
solve the problem I found I wasn't
getting I wasn't really getting answers
I wasn't getting Solutions I wasn't
being very creative of sitting down
lying down and having my body be still
where I get a lot more of my energy and
creativity and ideas when I'm moving so
I get a lot of ideas
when I'm walking so I do a belief walk
every morning which is 30 to 60 minutes
I'll take the dogs out and then I'll go
for a walk usually the Tim Hortons grab
myself a coffee Canadian coffee brain
here and
No Agenda just think about what what am
I doing today you know what what day is
it what I want to accomplish today uh
take in some fresh air get a fresh
perspective and the the act of moving I
find gets my creativity flowing a lot
more I get ideas in the shower you know
when I'm when I'm moving have you got
ideas in the shower I think that's
meditation maybe it's a different
version of it a different definition of
it but I think that's meditation where
you can calm down when you can focus on
present and you get some great ideas to
come I'm selling my place we just bought
a new house we're selling this place and
the studio looks a little different
normally I'm filming in my car because
we're running some errands or my regular
studio and to get this place ready to
sell you you know we wanted to have a a
place that everybody could connect to
and so what my agent did was make an
office in a different room and I'm
sitting down and I have not sat down for
two years I don't know my last time I
like sat down to actually work and and
you might even notice me like I'm
Shuffling around a little bit like I
like to move normally I'm on a
trampoline and I'm bouncing 20 to 40 000
times a day and I got that because I
would find that when I did phone calls I
would much rather stand up and walk
around the office than just sit down and
so I'm a lot more creative and have a
lot more energy when I'm moving and
maybe that movement in my energy creates
movement in you know brain energy and
capacity and thinking creativity as well
but all of that is my form of meditation
and so anytime that I would challenge
you to at least consider the fact that
anytime that you're present anytime that
you are focused on something that you
can consider that part of the benefits
of meditation
the second part of meditation that I
haven't fully connected to yet and I
don't have a solution for yet is when
you access theta waves and that's
basically when you're bouncing between
conscious and subconscious and where you
feel like
time flies so for me when I sit down or
lie down doing a meditation
if it's 20 minutes it feels like 20
minutes and I don't think I'm hitting
any Theta levels
um I can sit there and be present and
focus on my breath or you know I've
chewed a cookie for half an hour or an
hour and never swallowed it you know
like the focus and the presence I can do
but it still feels like it's 20 minutes
or half an hour or an hour I've never
had a I sat down for an hour and I felt
like it was I was only on for five
minutes
I get that more through the work that
I'm doing I get that more
um I recently did a six hour uh q a with
Tom bilyu's impact community
on his Discord and
it was six hours I didn't go to the
bathroom I didn't take a break I was I
was reading the questions and answering
the questions my throat was burning
didn't even notice it till the end and
had that six hours flew where that felt
if you asked me how long was it I would
have said I don't know it was like 20
minutes half an hour like six hours six
hours later still going and then we
eventually wrapped it up because it
needs to go to dinner
my wife where I said yeah I'm gonna do
this short little q a and turned out to
be six hours
so maybe that's even a better form of
meditation maybe maybe when you're in
your purpose and doing great work and
time flies because you're having fun
maybe that is a better form of
meditation for you if you struggle with
just sitting down and meditating maybe
doing that work is healing you know I
think a lot of people meditate to heal
and I think of a part of why that could
work is because you're again removing
the stress of the past of the regret of
the past and removing the anxiety and
stress of the future and when your
body's all stressed out it's not going
to heal right but when you get back to
present and remove the stress you create
the conditions for healing in your body
well I remember when I broke my neck in
2019 and I kept doing my tour I kept
staying on it because I wanted to be
around entrepreneurs I wanted to keep
doing the I could have canceled the tour
wouldn't have been a big deal but that
became healing for me in feeling like I
was serving that I was helping sitting
at the front of a room for four hours
with
immobilized neck brace on ice packs you
know on my neck two or three pillows
behind me and I couldn't move for four
hours but just talk
that became healing for me
and so
at least what's helped me for where I'm
at right now I'm totally open to to new
experiences and being changed and you
know swaying my opinion before I'm at
right now
staying present
and doing
not just the work but doing activities
that you enjoy that you feel are in
service to others that you feel like
you're living your purpose that you feel
like you're having an impact think about
the things that you love doing where
where hours get lost I'm not talking
about like opening your phone and
scrolling through Instagram when you
realize that two hours have passed and
like how did I just waste all this time
not that but
in service of others and helping to see
I'm moving around right now I gotta move
I can't sit still
I don't like it when I get in creative
ideas I gotta move I play with my ring
you know they got the ring is all over
the place it's not just on my finger
this this gives me more creativity like
the motion creates more creativity for
me
and so if you find those things where
you love doing it's in service to others
is helping people time gets lost and you
feel it in your heart and your soul that
this is the right thing for you to be
doing for where you're at right now
that maybe that's you know maybe just
maybe that's the form of meditation that
you need the most
that
by staying present and helping others
and being in service maybe that's all
the healing that you need
maybe that is the present mind that you
need maybe that is the focus that you
need maybe that is the meditation that
you're already doing
and if that gives you some extra
perspective or a different view on
meditation what you might hear other
places I hope that helps maybe judge
yourself a little bit less or maybe lean
into something that you thought didn't
exist because it certainly played a huge
impact on my life and thank you for
allowing me to share the story with you
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want an amazing guided morning
meditation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe I'll see you there
if there are any tension spots in your
body that may have come from a difficult
dream during the night
just breathe into that area